hola buenas tardes un día histórico un
momento histórico europa está ahora en
el momento en el lugar ideal de la
historia así lo han asegurado los
líderes de las instituciones europeas
consideran que es un mensaje de enorme
calado político los líderes europeos han
apoyado sin fisuras que ucrania y
moldavia sean países que sean países
candidatos a entrar a la unión europea
después del voto de los líderes europeos
se podría decir por videoconferencia al
presidente ucraniano volodymyr zelinski
también a su homóloga de moldavia es la
primera vez en el caso de ucrania que se
le da el estatus de candidato a un país
que está en plena guerra el presidente
francés emmanuel macrón asegura que
estos países no se podían quedar con las
manos vacías y que había que dar un
gesto contundente es un enorme apoyo de
gran calado político como comentábamos
eso si no se da gratis porque en
cualquier caso estos dos países moldavia
y ucrania tendrán que tener una serie de
reformas como el estado de derecho
en la lucha contra la corrupción una vez
que se haya otorgado este estatus de
candidato una vez ahora ya lo tienen a
trabajar tendrán que seguir con las
reformas para poder empezar las
negociaciones un proceso que puede
tardar mucho pero el mensaje es muy
claro el presidente francés el manual
macro no ha sido muy claro también al
respecto asegura que ucrania está está
dispuesta a luchar por los valores
europeos y que merecían un gesto